number 10 I'm a huge motor sports and
car fanatic I have owned 30 cars thus
far in my life I raced cars for years
and yeah it's a bit of an addiction
number 9 I've never had a drop alcohol
in my life I know kind of kind of weird
puts me out there in that freakin nature
thing but it's true number 8
I am the grandson of a cotton farmer my
grandfather was from Texas my dad's from
Texas I was born in Texas number 7 I
currently own 47 pairs of shoes sneakers
dress shoes a variety of things again I
kind of like shoes number 6 I once
played the kid of a mobster on the show
General Hospital for a 100 episodes
there there abouts number 5 being an
actor one of the cool perks is you can
you can tell your manager to set you up
with the girl if you for some reason
don't have confidence to talk to her in
that moment not that I've ever done that
but uh I'm gonna sound like a giant
douche number four I learned to drive at
age six out of my grandparents farm was
actually in my dad's lap at that point
but by age eight I could reach the
pedals and I would just drive number
three my secret celebrity crush well
after seeing the cover of GQ with Kate
Upton on it I think that kind of takes
the cake number two I am also a small
business owner of a graphic design firm
called Sur cometa
and I guess one of the coolest things
we've done in conjunction with another
company we just recently did a whole
bunch of graphics for YouTube's
headquarters which is kind of cool and
the number one fun fact about me is I
got some tattoos over the wintertime
first tattoos these are them they say
head up hammer down which for a car guy
like me basically means no matter how
tough it gets keep your head up and keep
going they are designed to wear
when my hands are on the wheel they're
actually legible so it's kind of an
extra little fun fact for you there make
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on candy other plodding weight episodes